da ich fahre noch da blablabla
hallo mein name ist luca und mir wurden
coole command zugesendet die stelle ich
euch jetzt vor der erste command ist von
super trouper hans und zwar seine
deutschland österreich und schweiz
flagge dafür geben wir erstmal ein / gfp
command unterstrich blog mir wurde
letztes geschrieben dass es irgendeinen
einfacheren befehl gibt aber ich bleib
bei dem world of xchange rolls take a
look ich bin ruhiger zu holen uns auch
noch hier eben einen hebel setzen den
command blog hinsetzen den hebel hin und
fügen doch diesen langen command ein und
drücken diesen hebel und dann sehen wir
schon daneben baut sich das irgendwie
auch ich weiß nicht warum allerdings
seht ihr schon hier jeden moment kommt
hier eine maschine hin genau da ist sie
und da kommen jetzt ein paar blöcke rein
und wir bekommen drei teams von zwei
creature mini flatrate austria fleck und
create switzerland
warum können wir jetzt einfach mal die
german trade beispielsweise hier
hinsetzen und ich weiß nicht ob ihr
irgendwo im wassersport oder hasi sport
im wasser aber davon haben wir jetzt
eine riesige deutschlandflagge wenn ich
rein theoretisch was ist wenn ich das
auf den gleichen noch mal drauf setzte
kommt man freunde wir alle zusammen zu
der kein langweiliger nur noch 15 kanal
machen das natürlich genau hier nochmal
gleich darauf mal schauen was etwas
ersetzt wird
es ist gut dass ich eine
deutschlandflagge genau auf die
deutschland tage gemacht hat also setzen
wir eine österreich flagge direkt dahin
wo wie die deutschlandflagge gespannt
haben und jetzt genau ist sogar ersetzt
das ist ja ganz okay das heißt wir haben
da hat die österreich flanke und wenn
ich euch mal die schweizer zeigen möchte
kommen die stelle ich jetzt mal hier
vorne hin wird hier jeden moment genau
die schöne gute alte unabhängige
schweiz der zumindest die flagge wird
hier und dann wenn wir wollen können wir
dann zwischen österreich und schweiz und
das ist so wie wenn ich an der grenze
zwischen den beiden her fahren würde und
ist ein super und wir machen weiter mit
command nummer 2 der zweite command ist
von mister gay tony staccato wir haben
immer wieder einen kommentar von mister
gay und so wie wir die minister ghetto
aus einigen der letzten folgen schon
kennen ist es kein command wo wir
einfach eine maschine gesagt bekommen
und die macht das alles rund sondern es
kommt so eine maschine aber wir müssen
die restlichen scheiß selber machen so
ist er minister ghetto finde ich aber
ganz cool dass er so ein bisschen
abwechslung rein bringen und zwar wird
der block oben erreicht wir haben hier
eine maschine und wir sehen schon
weekends command blockmodell has been
and style kommissar cato klick hier vor
kraft dem recipes und was ist wenn ich
das mache ich nicht dafür habt ihr ja
mich und zwar steht hier wieder ganz
normal nur canons bei mister ghetto und
man denkt sich erstmal was euch machen
aber dafür bin ich ja da und zwar
schmeißt ihr einen trichter bzw einen
hopper dorthin dann einen dispenser
beziehungsweise einen wärter und einen
string beziehungsweise einen faden und
wir sehen schon pendant ich habe im
inventar eine canon und da wo ich jetzt
hinschaue also keine canon kamera
sondern kennen kann ohne an alle die
jetzt dach und hat keiner wir machen
einfach weil da wo ich die kanone jetzt
quasi hin zeige das heißt wenn ich mal
so mache zeigt kann ohne dort hinten hin
wenn ich die kanone allerdings
beispielsweise hierhin zeige zeigt sie
dahin
hierhin zeigt die dorthin und wenn ich
hier rein theoretisch eine hinderte
zeigt sie nach da hinten in das geht in
alle vier himmelsrichtungen und jetzt
brauchen wir natürlich noch genau du da
vorm bildschirm
wir benötigen kanonenkugeln und die
machen wir zwei kanonenkugeln benötigen
wir tnt und eisen das heißt wenn ich
hier einen tnt hinschmeißen reisen
bekomme ich viel kanonenkugeln ich kann
noch mal den schmeißen nochmal alten
bekomme ich schon acht kanonenkugel mit
hinweise noch mal 4
und jetzt habe ich sogar schon zwölf und
wenn ich jetzt eine kanonenkugel einfach
mal mit cool drauf schmeiße wird das
direkt geladen und das tnt fliegt
einfach direkt ins wasser es ist jetzt
gerade ein bisschen scheiße weil wir uns
hier einfach einer kleinen insel
befinden allerdings hoffe ich mal dass
wir da hinten das festland erreichen und
wir das ist doch nicht wahr
aber dafür haben wir natürlich luca der
natürlich bei solchen situation mit
drängend also wir setzen die kanone hier
hinschmeißen dort einen cannonball run
action das tnt fit gelaunched und es
wird um das mal wieder richtig knapp
vorne und davon ist es dass tnt
explodiert und wir haben das erste mal
die kanone gelaunched sage ich mal
wenn man sich jetzt allerdings denkt so
eine explosion das ist ein bisschen zu
wenig dann könnt ihr da eine cannonball
hinschmeißen und dort halten nicht
wieder einsammeln luca da liegt der
cannonball willst mir die kanonenkugel
und da können wir einen tnt drauf
schmeißen dann seht ihr schon das hat
eine andere farbe bekommen wenn ich das
jetzt auch sammeln ist dass in den neuen
slot und zwar ist das fragment ation
cannonball was ich mit diesem blöden
flaggen hier anfangen soll weiß ich auch
nicht mehr so genau und wenn ihr jetzt
beispielsweise mal vergleicht wir hatten
hier mit kennern ist klaus zürn aber
okay da seht ihr man kann sie nicht
direkt nebenan arrangiert wieso kommt
ihr denn mal soviel feuerwehr der
niemals vergleich das hier vorne war die
kleine explosion von dem einen tnt
wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal
beispielsweise die kanone hier die habe
ich übrigens mit 60 wieder ein das heißt
ich muss da irgendwie rechtsweg
draufdrücken von so ein paar seiten und
dann jeden moment bin ich dann und dann
habe ich die sofort eingesammelt und das
ist eigentlich gar nicht so schwer
sondern das ist einfach nur man muss da
direkt und da habe ich die kanone
eingesammelt ich stell dir mal ein
bisschen näher daran damit wir nicht
gleich da irgendwo im wasser landen also
da tue ich jetzt nämlich mal den fleck
sensation keinen ball rein und ihr seht
schon das von zwar auch wieder nur ein
tnt aber das split sich auf 14 weitere
tnt so macht dem entsprechenden viel
größeren schaden
und ja wir gezeigt wenn ich die kanone
einsammeln möchte ich einfach nur im
freien vor einem slot und macht damit
rechtskräftig die kanone eingesammelt
und wir machen auch schon direkt weiter
mit chroma 3 bzw vorher muss ich euch
doch bevor wir zum q3 kommt echt
eigentlich somit der alkomat ist den ich
bisher fast je vorgestellt habe und zwar
geht es um eine sache wegen des von
schwäbisch hall angeschrieben wurde ja
schwäbisch hall man denkt sich
vielleicht erst mal sowieso schwäbisch
hall was hat denn das mit lukas kanal zu
tun
um ehrlich zu sein nicht allerdings ist
diese aktion sehr sehr cool deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich berichte euch
mal davon die haben also ein projekt
beziehungsweise kampagne die heißt band
sucht bleibe da gibt es dann immer ein
künstler bzw
and what ever die zu euch nach hause
kommen kann
sonst lieb and greet sag ich mal also
der band typ oder der sänger pendant bei
euch und diesmal ist das ganze mit mark
foster das heißt wenn ihr jemanden
kennen beispielsweise euer vater oder
mutter europa oder ihr selbst seid marc
forster fan das ist der der mann liebt
sido und so aufgenommen hat also meine
musik muss ich wirklich sagen ist es
nicht besonders aber ich finde die
aktion richtig cool wenn ihr denkt wow
das wird schillig wenn er mal zu mir
kommen würde und mein vater oder so
witzig mega freuen und wir haben ja auch
ein bett für den und bla dann hält er
quasi bei euch im wohnzimmer sein
konzert und kann auch bei euch kennen
und ihr könnt mit dem labern und so was
alles machen und die möchten wirklich
einfach leuten eine freude machen und
ich finde wenn ich jetzt irgendwas hätte
verkaufen müssen sich das nicht gemacht
aber das ist eine echt coole aktion und
ich finde es einfach echt hammer wenn
man damit leuten bestimmt weiß nicht
stellt euch wolle jemand es riesiger
marc forster fan und kann einfach
dadurch jetzt ihnen mal treffen
also ich finde das mega cool der macht
halt derzeit eine tour und das ist da
mal was anderes als ein simples blödes
meet and greet sondern entwickle ich bei
euch und kommt quasi neuer leben rein
sage ich mal
deswegen will ich die aktion ganz cool
findet link dazu einer beschreibung ist
euch überlassen ob die dropkick oder
nicht aber vielleicht könnte damit dem
ein oder anderen menschen eine freude
machen
blöd ist deutsch der dritte command den
ich euch heute vorstellen ist von meinem
guten freund den ich noch nie richtig
kennengelernt habe
minecraft und zwar füge ich diesen
chromatisch schon mal ein und dieses
wohl ganz kurz und ich drücke den
schalter und freut sich auf und in der
zwischenzeit wo sie das aufbaut sage ich
euch schon mal was es ist einfach schon
fertig aufgebaut ihr seht schon im chat
eingeblendet driver bei minecraft und ja
es stimmt es ist ein wirklich fahrbares
auto wir können hier einfach
draufklicken right click ceo items und
dann müssen wir für den rot gefärbten
ton nehmen darauf den obsidian setzt und
darauf eine rüstung ständer und wir
bekommen ein item was karl haist und das
können wir jetzt ganz einfach hier
hinsetzen und dann seht ihr schon okay
was ist das das ist quasi einfach nur
mein card denkt man sich jetzt
vielleicht erstmal dann kann sich
allerdings daneben stellen kann sich
nach einem letzten den weg schon im chat
starts beim auto oder halt stopp und
speed ist erst mal 0,1 und novartis auf
prof und ich gehe es mal den hof von und
drückt wenn man auch staat damit ihr
seht dass ich jetzt quasi oben
und zwar kommen jetzt erst mal die
richtigen farben ins spiel und zwar so
sieht das ganze aus in die richtung wo
ich hinschaue fährt dieses auto hin das
heißt ich schaue noch da ist da ich
fahre nach da bla bla bla und das jetzt
quasi seehofer mode ich gehe immer
weiter runter weil es der hofer mode ist
einfach wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise in
den chat dienst bieten auf 0.5 machen
seht ihr schon das ding geht ab wie
schmidts katze ich kann jetzt mit 0 5
speed das ist glaube ich so wie wenn ich
sprinten würde oder normal fahren würde
ich bin mir halt normal gehen würde ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher das ist nicht
so schnell oder wie als wenn ich halt so
ganz normal gehen würde und diese in der
hofer bot der der lotse mich immer so
ein bisschen wieder nach oben setzen
grad wieder nach oben geschickt den kann
ich allerdings auch ausmachen das heißt
hold off und jetzt lande ich hier auf
dem boden und fahre jetzt hier mit einem
0 5 geschlagen und ihr seht schon ja das
bin ich in einem auto und genau so sieht
es auch aus wenn ich irgendwie
autofahrer das ist einfach dann schick
ich bin luca geht es gut mir geht es gut
hier alles gut ja scheiße ich bin jetzt
grad unter wasser aber da fallen mir den
hof das heißt wenn ich mal hott von
pickel seht ihr auch schon wow ich habe
mich immer mehr und jetzt bin ich schon
wieder in der luft um draußen cool war
es ihm ja das ist command nummer drei es
ist ein 34 beziehungsweise fast schon
flugzeug weil ich damit herum fliegen
kann ich ja wenn du das machst du
vielleicht mal flugzeug wenn er das mit
dem fliegen die mit dem auto schnell
kriegt hast kannst du ja mal ein
flugzeug machen also find ich cool
das würde ich sagen ich weiß noch ein
bisschen im auto romy findet natürlich
alle links irgendwie einerseits zu
dieser schwäbisch hall kampagne was ich
echt cool findet sonst hätte ich richtig
gemacht ich möchte jetzt nicht dass
irgendwelche kommentare kommen so redete
ich denke wie damals nur so was ich
finde es ist eine coole aktion man kann
läuten damit echt eine freude machen und
ich verkörpere das euch echt so weil ich
ehrlich zu euch sein möchte das video
wird natürlich unterstützt von
schwäbisch hall aber ich find die aktion
einfach cool
ich weiß nicht wer da was gegen hat ist
glaube ich echt ein mensch der mit
anderen menschen nicht gerne freude
macht aber egal ich würde euch sagen
wenn es euch gefallen habe ich mich über
die bewertung freunde findet links zu
command familien von wem das ist so wie
immer eigentlich tschüss
herr drauf